he is vulnerable and infectious but the
president
is going home he's he's back yeah
signed off by his ever optimistic
medical team
though he may not entirely be out of the
woods yet the team and i agree that all
our evaluations
and most importantly his clinical status
support the president's safe return home
where he'll be surrounded by world-class
medical care 24
7. three days after his oxygen levels
dropped
midway through an antiviral treatment
and while
still on steroids america's most
high-profile covid patient
has been allowed to leave we all remain
cautiously optimistic and on guard
because we're in a bit of unchartered
territory when it comes to a patient
that received the therapies he has so
early in the course
so we're looking to this weekend if we
can get through to monday
with him remaining the same or improving
better yet
then we will all take that final deep
sigh relief
the writing was on the wall perhaps with
this parade
in a packed car determined not to be a
victim
he's now casting himself as a learned
survivor tweeting
i'll be leaving the great walter reed
medical center today at 6
30 p.m feeling really good don't be
afraid of covid don't let it dominate
your life
we've developed under the trump
administration some really great drugs
and knowledge
i feel better than i did 20 years ago
but he is also 74 years old obese
on an experimental drug cocktail and
returning to a white house
engulfed by the virus his press
secretary
kelly mcinerney maskless in front of
reporters yesterday
today confirmed she has it and the
numbers in washington
are steadily rising 11 people many close
to the president
have officially confirmed they have
coronavirus
they include the first lady his close
adviser hope hicks
his press secretary and two of her team
members of the president's debate team
and other senior republicans we've been
told the president's medical
team will check that there is no live
virus in him
that he could transmit if they're
satisfied he could return to the trail
very soon his own physician described
him as a phenomenal patient but
what he wouldn't tell us was when the
president's last negative test was
the world's most powerful man has got
his wish
back to the seat of power it could be
the making of him
it could also be the undoing cordelia
lynch sky news washington